all right guys
bang bang i've got nikki here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
thanks bob for having me absolutely
let's jump right into
your background uh where did you grow up
and what did you do
before you started uh building companies
sure so i'm from germany originally my i
was born and raised in munich my parents
are from argentina so they moved from
argentina to germany
i was born and raised in munich so we're
my two brothers and we spend
a lot of summers german winters
argentinian summers in south america
went to school in germany ended up fast
forward playing golf on the german
national team for a while
so i used to there was a time when i
thought i'll be a professional athlete
um didn't pursue golf much further
instead went to college
studied computer science and finance
took a job in a renewable energy startup
in germany traveling to asia a lot and
then in 2011 i moved
to the us to go to business school and
then at business school in stanford
that's where
i met my co-founder and we started our
first company right after
so talk a little bit about stanford and
going to business school there you
obviously had this amazing experience
uh you got close with uh somebody who
previously has been on the podcast and
andy
uh maybe just talk about the experience
a little bit and kind of how that served
as a foundation for uh for some stuff
you've done professionally
yeah so you go into business school
expecting a lot of things
and then you find you're getting
something completely different out of it
so i don't it's not a crazy
academic experience so it's not like you
learn accounting unless you want
to like you can make your choices
instead in my case i really wanted to
absorb everything around technology and
venture capital entrepreneurship that
was one of the reasons why i moved to
the us i really wanted to get into tech
and thought business school in stanford
in the valley would be would be a good
way to do so
and uh like i couldn't have set higher
expectations and yet everything was
way exceeded including because i was
lucky and had a class with andy racleff
where we've really dissected startups
and
looked at startups and understood why
some of them are working and
what to strive for when you build your
own company yeah so for those that don't
know andy who previously came on
uh is a co-founder of benchmark and uh
has been in silicon valley for
at this point 30 years probably uh and
just had this epic epic career talk a
little bit about when you
said okay i do want to go start a
company where did you know who the
co-founder was already going to be
did you already have the idea or kind of
what process did you guys go through to
kind of select co-founder and then also
to uh to settle on an idea to go after
yeah i think i think you'll laugh so
first of all no startup story like
they're all
look so romantic with hindsight no
startup stories like
i had the idea i did it and it worked so
in my case i i was like desperate to
start a company just didn't know what to
start a company
in like which industry because you
really want to be authentic to the space
and the space i've been most authentic
at that point was golf like i was good
at golf but i didn't want to start a
golf startup
and so i was looking around and trying
to have insights and trying to learn and
realize i'm i'm not learning anything
that gives me a crazy edge in a crazy
space
and uh part of business school is going
on a lot of trips with your classmates
and so chris
my co-founder and classmate at the time
uh and a bunch of friends and i traveled
through vietnam and then
i got him to talk about cars and he's a
huge car enthusiast
like crazy his first car was a delorean
the the one from back to the future he
had just gotten back
from from the uk where he interned at
mclaren
because he wanted to work for a formula
one company went there
loved the product didn't like the type
of business and like the culture
and so he was a little disappointed
because the
job after business school was going to
be a formula one company
and then he went and it's like meeting
your childhood here like he wasn't very
impressed after all
and then i asked him so what what what
do you find interesting in the car space
and
he like i pressed the right button he
just kept talking about everything he
understood and knew and i was so
impressed
he knows everything i thought and then
he said there is
one model that he particularly finds
particularly interesting
it's the what's called buy here pay her
model or where
underbanked americans or immigrants go
to the car dealership to get a loan in
the car
so they don't go to their bank because
the bank wouldn't give an extent alone
instead the dealership does it
and he said that's a space that's right
for disruption it's a very messy
customer experience
and if he had a if he had a
entrepreneurial ambitions that's
something he'd look into
and i said well i got some
and then we started looking into the
space like we started visiting these
dealerships pretending
and this poor guy from germany who just
moved here needs a car no credit
and started learning we've quickly found
that that's not a space where you want
to start
but while we were exploring the space
all our classmates knew
that we were exploring something in the
car space and chris was the one to talk
to
about cars and when we graduated all our
classmates needed to sell their car so
naturally they asked us for advice
and then we went from giving advice to
selling our classmates cars and
craigslist
very quickly and so when you're doing
this
um is it a thing where okay let's go
look
like let's start a company and let's go
figure out the car space
is it uh our classmates keep coming
coming to us and asking us to sell
cars for them and so we get like pulled
into starting a company because it's
just like such a no-brainer once you get
started like
like at what point are you like okay
this goes from like an intellectual
exercise around
the car industry could use disruption to
we're starting a company yeah i think
that's a really good question because
i wasn't realizing at the time that
we're in the process of starting a
company
like i i thought you need to have so
much conviction and you have to have
products and you have to have customers
and then you can call it across a
company
so i didn't i didn't know what we're
doing i didn't know we were slipping
into
starting a company the one thing we had
learned
and uh taking to heart was what andy
rector have taught us
is that the most important thing about
starting a company is finding value
like you need to find product market fit
you need to find something that if you
put it out there
people talk about it and they come and
beg you to provide that
and chris was the one who had the
insight or the realization quicker than
me
i was just laughing at my classmates who
started asking us can i sell their cars
because
i'm also graduating from stanford like
i'm not going to sell your car
why would i and chris like i think
there's value here
i think people want us to provide a
service that i know i can provide
and that sounds very much like product
market fit or at least
like a chance at discovering something
so why don't we do it
and like it took him maybe 10 minutes to
convince me okay let's sell one car
so we detailed it took photos put it on
craigslist
and then indeed found buyers that person
was paying for the car we returned the
money to the seller and he couldn't
believe how much money we got for this
car because he had the benchmark he had
was what dealerships were offering
and then like a light bulb went down
when we realized this is value we can
provide
so another question is how can we
provide it to more people
and it wasn't even then it was when when
andy and i grabbed a beer and i told him
hey i've been selling cars all summer
but now i need to figure out with my
life when he said i think you should be
selling cars and he has 50 000
to get started that's when i realized
that this might actually be a startup
and so did you think that this was like
hey we're doing this manual and we can
go build technology to do it better
or was it well if we're already doing it
we're making some money we'll just do
more of it
and like we'll just hire a bunch of
people and then at some point down the
road you figure out oh technology is a
better solution
like how intentional was this a
technology company versus just like
let's serve the customer and kind of
solve this pain point yeah
now the intention was to find value no
matter what we did a lot of things that
didn't scale and we didn't care
like the the goal was to provide value
if somebody
pays you for what you do you clearly
provided value
if you can attract other people who may
not be in the stanford network that's a
really good sign too
so we ended up just walking into the
tesla dealerships because tesla didn't
have a trading program at the time
and we told the sales guys hey do you
have a problem with people wanting to
trade in cars like yeah it's a huge
problem our experience is so clunky
we said just put them in touch with us
so we'll sell their cars privately
and hopefully give them a lot of money
back and so these were all really good
signs
and then at some point we realized so
the incremental car that we needed to
sell
was uh so much more effort because we
like we were there in person during test
drives
and so that's when we asked ourselves
how can we leverage technology
to remove friction or scale this
business and
the the conviction we had if we create
an experience like zipcar where you can
swipe your id
and let somebody test drive by himself
we wouldn't have to be there in person
for people who either didn't show up or
showed up late
and in reality we're creating a much
better experience if we let customers
test drive these cars by themselves
and so that's where technology came in
and all of a sudden
scales the business or the operations by
a lot because we could have
40 40 parallel test drives versus having
to be at all of these test drives
in person and spend an hour with
somebody who might not even buy the car
and so as you're doing this uh one of
the things that's always fascinated me
is and we'll get to kind of the
financialization of everything right is
it's just digital commerce in many cases
uh when this first started out people
wanted to buy books or electronics or
kind of toiletries or whatever on the
internet that was like
a pretty big leap like oh well okay i'm
not gonna go to the store i'm just gonna
like use the internet and then it's
gonna like somehow show up okay uh but i
don't think people thought you're gonna
buy cars
or homes or anything you know kind of
big life purchases on the internet now
we see that right
through a whole bunch of different
companies uh but you guys kind of held
on to this one part of the experience
that
made it not 100 digital which was you
started to go test drive the car
right and so talk a little bit about was
that like a
a point of we are not going to
compromise on this we know that people
want to test drive these and so we have
to bake that into the experience
or how did you guys kind of hold on to
that even though you were really
building kind of a digital
technology enabled uh buying experience
yeah you're completely right so we we
just tried to marginally change
the status quo to create a business and
so
we actually went through y combinator
and skilled the business to ex
to an extent where it started breaking
the next customer experience wasn't as
good as the previous one
we were frustrated we weren't providing
good customer experiences
there's a seller in dubai we always
every time we had a deal come
come to fruition both our customers were
unhappy so clearly we
we somehow like found something that was
interesting but it wasn't going too big
a big
be a big business and then we took a big
step back and asked ourselves so
if we can't serve the seller in the
buyer at the same time
what if we focus on one of them and
figure out how to make it an
exceptional value proposition for them
and so we looked into
can we offer sellers more money through
technology and the answer was no it's a
commodity
and then we looked into how can we help
buyers and we realized well there's the
wholesale auction that's the marketplace
where dealerships get their inventory
from
200 000 of cars every day a lot of them
in really good condition
need very little reconditioning should
and could go directly to the consumer
but due to the structures in the space
needed to first go to the dealership
and then to the customer and we said
okay so this
may be crazy because our whole bet
wasn't scaling the test drive
what if we just remove the test drive
and allow people to have access to a
channel where they usually don't have
access to
to get inventory and so we we were in
every pitch conversation
every conversation around how do you
think the car space will evolve
we changed our opinion overnight from
there has to be a test drive to there
can't be a test drive
and then we needed to prove it to
ourselves that we can sell cars 100
online without test drive and just
guaranteeing
seven days money back in case there's
something wrong with the car
into the first conversation as you can
imagine where were
what are we doing no i'm not going to
buy a car site on scene and hang out
other people thought we were scammed and
left yelp reviews
um and we're like oh shoot we need to
figure this out and then the first
person to buy a car from us
was an older gentleman 65 years old
who had a car on lease the lease ran out
and he was offered to buy the car at a
lease but we were offering the car so
much cheaper because we had gave him
direct access
to the wholesale inventory that he said
it's so so cheap
compared to what i'm being offered i i
can't say no to this
like if you guarantee the condition i'll
buy the car set and seeing because it's
the same car that i already had
and so this person walked in wrote a
check drove away and had a phenomenal
experience and then we said
holy moly we need to sell cars online
like we need to do this online and
disrupt the value chain
compress margins and that's actually a
much better business that skills much
better
and so that's how we kind of slipped and
certainly fell
into the online car retailing model if
that makes sense
yeah what's so interesting to me here is
like you found a place where there was
value you kind of wedged yourself in
began
to really really understand it and
become experts at this one piece of
the car market and then you figured out
how to scale it and then you figured out
how to make it efficient and how to have
good margins and things like that
and really like that is the way that if
you kind of
drew it up it's supposed to work right
it is kind of
you you almost have to do this stuff
sequentially and it feels like so many
people try to just
jump to the finish line and have this
grand plan but you don't get that
journey along the way to kind of really
dial in what the value proposition is
yeah i think there's actually there's
two ways to start a company
and one is the very lean way how do we
did it
spend very little money we really nimble
and just iterate iterate iterate
there's the other extreme which is just
be a visionary and tell you i
i know how the future is going to look
like i'll just build it and then i think
the truth is the combination of both
something i admittedly learned from
ernie garcia who started carvana
he always he always had the future in
mind but he was
he was willing and scrappy to iterate to
a place
where he tested learned tested learned
tried out things and then he came up
with crazy ideas like vending machines
that
all of a sudden everybody loved so he
does a really good job in combining the
two things
um and i feel like having gone through
the experience being really scrappy and
doubling down too much on let's iterate
until we find something
that was a good learning and it taught
me that part now and the new business
that we're starting
i have a clear vision in mind on what i
want to do and what i want to achieve
and i need to figure out what's the best
angle to get there and we can talk about
this in a second too
absolutely and so as you guys are
building just talk a little bit about
how you actually scaled the business
right so you figure out okay this is
what we're building with this the
technology we've got to build
now comes the execution of just we got
to do it and so how does that play out
and kind of how big did the company get
yeah so we we pivoted from the
peer-to-peer model to the direct to
consumer model
that company that business value
proposition started taking off
and we had a lot of advisors and abc's
we had been in touch with
very closely uh in in in regular
communication with and giving them
updates on how we're doing
and all of a sudden i wrote an email and
i didn't even notice i did that i wrote
an email if we had more capital we could
grow faster
like i i'd never said that for two years
because i didn't believe it
and subconsciously i felt okay so the
next thing that we'll run out of the
next
bottling we'll have is capital because
we had to finance these cars for a week
they were on our balance sheets for a
week
um and then one investor calls back and
says i've been in touch with you guys
for a year and a half
i love how scrappy you are you've never
asked me for money and you just wrote if
you had more money
you could scale faster i would invest
and so that kicked off
serious a and that happened within four
weeks
just because we had the relationship
with the investors and i said the right
thing without knowing
and then the transition from scrappy
founders literally working out of a
garage where it's hot in the summer and
cold in the winter
and two or three team members to
building a company that scales
that was a transition where we started
to hire the executive team
we hired somebody who had sales and
marketing we hired somebody who did
took care of financing because when you
when you buy and sell cars
you move a lot of money very quickly um
and then we
we brought in head of operations
actually now our first employee became
the head of operations
just to scale everything and then we
built in a team and so the next step was
to validate that we can produce growth
uh predictably that's then the target
for the sears a capital
at the time at least and so what we
found we scaled
to i think we're selling 150 cars a
month that doesn't sound like a lot
in absolute terms but that's three and a
half million dollars in revenue that
we're turning every month
um each unit was profitable our problem
was
two things number one we we every sale
incremental sale became harder not
easier because the first people we
talked to were uber drivers lyft drivers
people who had a car
lease wanted to replace it with the
exact same car and own it
and then after we hit 150 sales a month
we tapped into the market where people
had saved for this car for a year or two
and became really emotional about the
purchase
carbine is very emotional and so we
underestimated that that was hard
and the the reason that was especially
hard is we couldn't finance anybody with
credit scores below 700 so we could only
finance customers through our credit
union network
that had exceptional credit and if you
can't finance people
buyers with credit scores below 700
you're you're excluding the majority of
americans
out of the equation and that's why the
model wouldn't work
got it and so as you're doing this um
you obviously build a
pretty big business right in the sense
of you're doing three and a half million
dollars a month in revenue
um did you kind of get to the point
where you realized wait this can be
a really really big business did you get
to the point where you said hey
we actually think that kind of
partnering up with somebody makes sense
like how did your thought from i want to
start a company okay now i got the
company now i know what i want to build
we're scaling
like what was the next thought in that
journey so this is i'm going to tell you
a story that
usually entrepreneurs don't tell you we
wanted to build a really big company but
we felt stuck
like we had this really nice trajectory
and had you drawn out
how our sales grew and how they became
more predictable it would have looked
really nicely and then we had a ceiling
like it was more obvious to us than to
anybody else we could have squeezed out
more sales but
it wasn't growing like that it was
growing like that and so we said
sure we have a problem here because we
could raise more money like i'm sure we
could have raised more money
but i don't think we'll do the hockey
stick um and so at the time we then
reached out to what felt
like competitors but we were all on the
same mission to change how users are
being bought and sold
um and got in touch with our now friends
at carvan
and just said let's compare notes we're
in the same space
we showed them what we had built we had
become really good at describing
vehicles 100 online because we had to
describe the vehicle
vehicles in in our inventory because
they weren't in our physical possession
and that's something carvana had planned
on building out
soon and then they said why don't we
just team up like your tech is really
great
why don't you want to apply it to a much
bigger base and we're growing like that
and we can finance customers below 700
credit score and we have the full
vertical integration so we're able to
provide an even better customer
experience
and then it was pretty compelling to
just bridge the efforts and we brought
our whole team
mainly product engineering and joined
forces with corvanna in 2017.
all right so this is the part of the
story that gets crazy because you you
merge with uh
carvana uh still very good situation for
yourself the employees investors
uh and then all of a sudden carvana goes
public uh
i guess one did you guys have an
understanding that that was
gonna happen or maybe it was like some
at some point in the future and then two
is once you get public the stock price
takes off and like you know
it's this kind of crazy situation but
just talk a little bit about kind of
going from
uh startup founder to a founder who's
scaling to a founder who sold their
business to next you know you're
basically running a division inside of a
publicly traded company
yeah things happen really quickly but
that's true for everybody at carvana
so the way i tell the story is that
usually
you either ride it through you start a
company and you you make it and then you
have the full journey
or you hit some bump in the road and
then you sell it or you find a way to
get out
and then you do something new and so we
were incredibly lucky because we
we had this whole journey for four years
to a certain point
and then instead of getting out because
we couldn't grow much further
and starting something new we just
switched lanes like we continued our
journey more or less exactly where we
ended it with our own company and then
continued
on what became a rocket ship um we knew
that carvanha was
going to go public when we first talked
to them
that made the the transaction a lot more
interesting for us too because we knew
like we had equity in these businesses
and we wanted to make sure that we have
for for the four years of suffering
underpaying ourselves that we get
something out of it and so knowing that
carvana
was going to be public was compelling um
the company went public at 15 and it
didn't take off immediately actually
went down to eight dollars
and until nobody tells that story and
ernie laughs about it now obviously
um by the time our first cliff
ended so after a year the first time we
could sell shares we were at
55 and at that point it was pretty clear
this was a good deal for us
so what are you thinking when the stock
goes from 15 to 8
and then what are you thinking when it
goes from 8 to 55
so from 15 to 8 we weren't thinking a
lot because it happened so quickly like
okay i guess it's eight not 15.
um when it goes from 8 to 55
we we wanted to prove ourselves i think
especially chris and myself the two
founders we really wanted to prove to
carvana it was a good decision to bring
us on board like
they extended a lot of trust to us and
they made a bet what felt like a big bet
on us
and so the first year we were just
really really busy
hey chris was integrating what we had
built at calypso
and i i was looking into areas where i
could be influential
and so what felt really good is that
after a year actually the six month mark
it started become obvious that
we could actually contribute to what
they're building and doing and so that
for good we became really good
friends with the founders and executives
over there and it felt like hours it
started
that usually doesn't happen or doesn't
happen often
but we had our babies within this big
company which
in like in these sales of companies or
acquisitions oftentimes the founders
feel like uh my baby is now somebody
else's and
so we didn't feel like that very much
instead we felt the opposite we felt
like we had ownership over really
interesting areas of the business we
felt like we were contributing
and then by the time we could sell for
the first time it felt a little bit like
a relief because we had we had been
massively underpaying ourselves
for four years when we ran the company
um
that and so that helped a little bit and
then the other thing is we
we needed to convince our team that
making the move to carvana was a smart
decision
um and more than looking out for
ourselves we actually looked out for our
team quite a lot
and knowing that they had a good outcome
felt really good and now they're
are good friends and we're like we
take a little bit of credit for them
being successful financially and being a
lot more independent than they were
before and so that felt really really
good
and then it became interesting to go
from 55 to 120
and then go from 120 to i think 25 when
covet hit over two weeks
and then then uh yeah now i don't know
where the stock price is but it's a lot
higher than that
and and now it feels like a relief that
like that
like this initial vision we all had that
used cars should be bought and sold
online is actually happening
like kovid kovet accelerated that
process as well
just like it accelerated a lot of other
other e-commerce and digitization
efforts
uh the same is true for car sales the
story of kind of stomaching that level
of volatility in a stock is incredible
so kudos to you guys for uh
for stomaching as much as you did uh
look away for weeks you can't like i
know people who attract the stock price
every day
like the fact that i don't know just
speaks for the fact that i'm really
looking away and i hate when people tell
me where it is because it's like that
but i'm like small compared to other
shareholders and carvanas i i feel for
them too
absolutely so talk a little bit about uh
kind of covet obviously accelerated a
lot of these digitization trends right
so
things that were kind of already
underway buying cars online is a great
example
uh it feels like we just got thrown
forward you know three to five years uh
into the future
uh and it really co-enforced these
trends to accelerate
how how has it played out kind of from
your perspective yeah
i as sad cobit is for many reasons i
think
there's there's a little bit of
excitement that i'm feeling about
like humanity making progress like from
a tech perspective
carvana was really really good for us
and to us
after three years chris and i ended up
deciding to move on
the reason we moved on is because we we
felt like this is a huge opportunity
we we've always felt that customers are
overpaying on car loans
like when people bought cars from us and
we found a loan for them which that's
true for 80
of the car loans they originated the
dealership we
knew that you could give a customer a
loan that's not ideal for the customer
but pays the dealership the highest
referral fee and so we always felt
car loan refinancing should be a bigger
thing than it is
and then when we heard about um
when prove it happened and we talked to
a lot of customers and realized
they're they're having financial
difficulties we again
came up with this thought if you
refinanced if you only refinanced your
car you could tap into the positive
equity in your car
it's actually a really creative way to
to access cash
and then the third insight we had and
i'll tell you where i'm going with this
in a second the third insight we have is
people who make their payments when they
when they take out a car loan
they're migrating credit and so for
people with exceptional credit the
difference isn't that big but if you
migrate from a 620 credit score to a 680
or 700 you can literally go from 10
to 4 on your car loan and nobody helped
customers
and the main reason i think nobody
helped customers
refinance their car auto loans or the
main reason people didn't do it is
because it used to be a fully
offline process part of refinancing is
auto loan refinancing
is the dmv so the dmv is part of your
funnel and if you have to exchange
paperwork
like you can't provide a good value
proposition yet now there is
like this big inflection point of of
transactions moving online and branches
being closed
you create incredible opportunities for
fintech
for in our case refinancing of auto
loans and we felt it was so compelling
to
to double down on that that we ended up
leaving carvana in june i think to start
or work on starting a new company
and so really what you're kind of
writing is uh two different trends right
one the
digitization of a lot of things if not
everything
uh and also the financialization of
everything talk a little bit
just at a high level how you see these
two things kind of
merging or kind of moving side by side
and really kind of taking over
um i laugh and say that uh the saying of
like software's eating the world
it feels like these are the the next two
trends right between digitizing things
and
financializing them so talk a little bit
about that yeah i think carvana is a
really really good example
fully vertically vertically integrated
business it's a tech company
it's a car dealership it's a logistics
company but it's also a bank basically a
lender
and so carvana creates an incredible
experience also because
you can get your loan get your loan on
the spot it's like
it fuels the transactions it's what we
were missing when we were selling cars
in our business
and we we didn't know it at the time in
fact it took chris and me probably a
year and a half to understand to fully
understand the power of
point-of-sale financing when you do
online car sales like a firm is a good
example
um think of a firm within carvana that's
what corvalli is practically
and so in actually in 2000 or 2001 there
was a company called imotors
said okay internet let's sell cars cars
online they build these used car
factories
i think part of the reason that didn't
take off it was a little bit
too early but you also need to be fully
vertically
integrated you need the fintech the
financing portion of the business to
really
fuel the business and nobody has done it
better than carvana is doing it inside
it's one of the examples
that i think show how important fully
integrating financing in your solution
it is to to actually disrupt a certain
market
i feel like the whole idea of like this
vertical integration really what
technology companies are realizing is
you can have the best technology in the
world but
when you are still relying on vendors
and kind of different suppliers and
different service providers they just
aren't
the same right they have different
expectations of how they interact with
their customers they
kind of just treat them in a very
different way and so if you could start
to
vertically integrate your technology
with the type of customer
support or care that you want with the
financialization
or kind of financial resources that they
need you really start to like
own the customer experience from the
second somebody says i want to buy a car
all the way through and that to me feels
much more defendable or much more of a
moat
uh because literally you own the entire
funnel right yeah
it's interesting because i think you
mentioned it earlier in the conversation
now even houses are like houses are sold
online
open door is such a good example of they
call it the full stack owning the full
stack of what is necessary to provide a
good customer experience
open door started as a data company like
the guys and we talked to them early
because it was so similar to our
business selling cars and buying cars
and selling and
buying houses is so similar open door
pitched itself as
like a data company knowing prices and
nuances of prices on properties better
than anybody else
and i think if you ask them today they
would admit no no the secret is full
stack
having the full stack of everything
that's connected and necessary to do a
house transaction
a property transaction under one roof
allows you to extract more margin
that means you can compress margin more
that means your offering becomes more
compelling and it's the better
experience
and it clearly seems to be what's
winning in the in the property space
but it is guaranteed to be what what
compel corvanna or makes cover so
compelling because it's
like you own every bit of the
transaction it's really hard to do
because that means you're running
multiple business at once
but if you get it right you have a mode
100
how do you think about sequentially
building that right because there's a
lot of people who say okay i want to own
the full stack but
it would be near impossible to go out
and just build it all from day one so
is it a thing where let's start at the
very top of the funnel kind of
dominate there and then kind of move
downstream as we go
do you start downstream do you try to
pick kind of where in the funnel you're
gonna start from a strategic standpoint
like how do you just think sequentially
building it out to eventually eat the
entire funnel
yeah i i don't think i have the perfect
answer i think
the examples that we see that are very
successful open door is a good example
you require a little bit more capital
than you otherwise would require to
build a startup
the open door was very well funded
carvana was very well funded
um so i don't have i don't think i have
the perfect answer for you
these businesses i think cannot be
started started by first-time founders
because you can't
you can't raise the money do you need a
race for some of these businesses
um which that's not a problem but
because somebody will do it it's great
if you do it you need a little bit more
capital and i think the other thing you
need you need to have the courage to
potentially acquire
somebody else like a vertical that you
can't quickly build
and bring it in house much earlier than
you would otherwise
and so actually a good example is vroom
room is the other online car seller
they started out trying to sell used
cars online and they quickly noticed
they could get like a huge huge
acceleration in the business
if they just bought somebody else who's
already good at doing it and so room
early on
raised venture funding to buy a company
called texas auto
direct they were the biggest used car
seller
that sold cars purely online mainly
through ebay at the time
and so for them they they bought the
stack and then optimized and built a
really big business i think that's one
way to do it
but again serial founders was the
founders of wix who started
room and they had they had the ability
to raise enough money to actually pull
it off i think is that the main
advantage to second or kind of multiple
time founders is the ability to access
uh capital uh i'm early in my second
journey so i can't speak for myself
um i can tell you that uh the things you
said
people start believing quicker so you
need to do a little little less
convincing i think
this is something that andy said and i
think it's true
i'm now very authentic to the space like
i've just through seven years in the car
space learned so much that when i talk
i can reference things and data points
and players and names and companies
and behaviors that i couldn't have
referenced seven years ago
and i think that makes the pitch really
compelling like even if i had nothing
and tell you what i want to work on i
think you you'd understand that i
understand this place very well
that doesn't mean i'm successful i think
it just means that i'm very authentic
and being offended to the space is very
helpful in starting businesses
that makes sense and as you think about
building the next business are there
things that you specifically are going
to do different
or kind of or lessons learned from
business number one that you'll
implement for business number two
yeah i think there's hey don't repeat
the same mistakes because there were
many
um b i mentioned that earlier
this time around it's i want to have i
do want to
do a better job communicating telling
myself in the team and reminding myself
what the mission mission is back then we
just said let's change how used cars are
being sold but this time around
we want to save americans a lot of a lot
of money around cars
like around car ownership partnership is
complicated it's more expensive than it
should be
um and so the mission is save americans
money
in car ownership the way exactly how we
get there i can't tell you quite yet we
could go directly to consumers
we're having a lot of conversations with
financial institutions
including credit unions believe it or
not who have really really great
products
and who struggle to get them to
customers so i can't tell you whether
they'll end up being a direct
consumer business or whether we'll end
up working with credit unions and help
them in their digitization efforts
but i can tell you that this time the
north star is very clear
um and i think part of the reason why it
wasn't so clear back then when we
started for the first time was
like when you leave business school
you're really eager and you have these
peers and you want to be successful
really quickly
while if you have this north star it
might take longer but at least you have
good direction
and i think i was lacking that at the
time and then frankly
ernie ernie always says you can't
climb up a hill or hike up a hill if you
continue to look at your feet
you need to remember where you're going
and so he uses that analogy a lot and i
think it's a really good one
i love that answer talk a little bit
about the
impact to the car industry from where
you guys sit whether it is uber lyft and
kind of ride sharing
or self-driving cars and kind of the
promise of that you know
always seems to be kind of two or three
years away yeah it's funny
when we raised money for the first time
in 2013
and versus building a car retailer
that's not a good idea because there'll
be autonomous cars
and everybody will drive uber this time
around
that question never came up um timing
was also interesting because uh
people are shifting to car ownership and
not away from it
so through the pandemic car sales are
through the roof because people want to
have their own cars
um autonomous cars had some some
incidents over the last three years that
slowed down that progress too
so i'm not worried about autonomous cars
or
car or or car sharing or uber lyft i
think it'll always exist and has a place
to exist
i think some of the trends take a little
bit longer
um but americans own so many cars it's
insane
there's 100 million car loans out there
so 100 million people owe money on cars
and a large large percentage of them are
overpaying so i'm
i'm just trying to help these people and
if i get even only a fraction of the
market it's going to be a big company
people underestimate how big the market
is carvana has a market share of
i think 0.6.7 not more not even one
percent of the car market
use car market and you can see how
valuable they are so it's a huge market
that's incredible like just just to
think of how big that market is
right yeah um you've got some very
interesting thoughts around
uh i'll call them fintech uh type
businesses
it seems like everyone today uh may not
have started out this path but they're
all
trying to be neo banks and yeah that's
everything from go get the actual
banking license to do everything you can
to be like a bank without actually
having to get the license uh i think you
guys can have a different perspective
explain maybe why
uh that may not be necessary or you see
a different path
yeah i'll i'll take a little segue to
end up
where the at the conversation you have
when i left germany the reason i never
started a tech company in germany was
because
in germany entrepreneurship and tech
companies meant
cloning a business network somewhere
else and so the conviction
always was if it works in the us humans
are the same the internet the same all
over the world
we'll just take these same businesses
and bring them everywhere
and uh in some cases it worked and
others it didn't
um you had these scooters in some places
actually in the original places in china
they didn't work but then everybody
tried to do it everywhere else
um and so neo banks i think a little bit
like that too where you have
a few examples like brazil for example
were
absolutely necessary incredible company
will definitely exist
it needs to exist but then there's other
markets that are not like brazil
where you probably don't need a neobank
but you're still getting the valuation
on your fundraise
like the other ones because it looks so
similar vs i don't know it
so well so take what i what i'm saying
with a grain of salt but
i know the lending space really well the
auto lending space
and so if i wanted to start an auto
lender which would be
we could be full stack and become an
auto lender that would not be a good
business
because the existing lenders are really
good at what they're doing
the the best product in fact are
products that credit unions are offering
especially for people who have
exceptional credit they just have a
different problem they can't reach their
customers they can't engage their
members
good enough to make sure that members
get their perfect products
to put things into perspective so even
if you have a credit union that you work
with a credit union member of a credit
union
and you qualify for say two percent auto
loan the second you go to the dealership
there's a more than 50 chance that the
dealer will talk you out of
the credit union loan and into another
loan and then the credit union ends up
with having tons of members who have
loans
horse products with with other lenders
and other institutions and so i believe
that for the us at least in the lending
space the goal is not to vertically
integrate and become a lender the goal
is to help
credit unions in this example digitize
their efforts so they can engage their
members better reach out to them better
and create a better and more engaging
experience
and then it's almost a white label
neobank other than
having the full bank on your side and
then trying to compete
for customers although your product is
ultimately fundamentally not better than
the existing ones so that's how i think
about it
yeah so really it ends up at the same
place it's just a matter of
is it you as a software company or
technology company being a neo bank
or do you basically put the pieces
together to offer that experience to the
customer
uh but maybe you don't have to do it all
yourself right i think yeah for the
consumer you end up at the same place
you get the right product with a better
experience
the businesses are being built are very
different than the different scenarios
that's why when i said earlier one thing
i'm excited about is having there's a
long-term
vision of how i want the world to look
like it's very customer-centric i want
the experience
the auto lending and auto expense
experience for customers
and borrowers in the u.s to be much
better but i can't tell you yet whether
or not i'll be fully vertically
integrated and provide everything from
a car loan to warranties and insurance
products or whether i use
the existing products and just do a much
better job engaging the customer
and giving these providers who have good
products access to these members and
customers and so that's where we are in
our thought process too
that makes sense what um what's been the
biggest surprise so far in starting the
second company like what like what
the first company i think everyone
expects you know founders to kind of go
in
uh eyes wide and kind of bushy-tailed
and very naive and they get tons and
tons of surprises
most people don't talk about the second
company though and although you guys are
just starting
have there been any surprises yet that
that stick out
i think i was about to say
we we come across it much more cr is
much more credible and i'm like i'm at
the same stage of the company as i was
last time when i got all the no's now
people are more inclined to say yes
just because i happen to have been at
the right place at the right time a few
times
um but the more valuable lesson is how
you're still learning so much
like there's i've heard that from a lot
of i've had two
dangers when starting your second
company multiple times number one you
jump into
the first opportunity to quickly because
you really want it and
then you feel like you know more now and
so you're listening less
i think the second one is a real risk
and we're
we're proving to ourselves that
listening to credit unions and customers
and members and other partners
proves really valuable because you have
so many surprises that you otherwise
overhear or don't take seriously and so
we spend a lot of time on the phone
which is great because you can talk to
so many people over zoom there
um learning and learning and learning
and we're learning so much like our
learning curve is much steeper still
than we expected and so
um yeah i'm enjoying that part actually
quite a lot
talk a little bit about um kind of how
you see consolidation in the space
um you know it's very obvious i think
that lots of people want to go
and uh now want to sell cars online for
example they see carvana's success and
like that's a great idea i'm gonna go
raise a bunch of money and go try to do
that
uh and what we've seen across tech
companies or industries is
uh they can get access to capital they
want to go buy things and sometimes they
buy
each other other times they buy the
incumbents or kind of smaller players
that have legacy models is there a world
where maybe we see the reverse like in
the car industry where
some of the larger players say no we're
going to buy the tech companies
and integrate them and so it's not
necessarily the tech companies being the
acquirers
uh or do you think that the dna of kind
of a startup venture-funded
tech business is just so different than
kind of these legacy businesses
that it's unlikely the the older
businesses the more established
businesses will be the acquirers
um good question the car space is unique
because it goes back to you you really
need to own the full stack
to to be able to provide a compelling
value proposition
and so what you're seeing is that the
existing players existing car
dealerships and groups
they're trying to figure out how can
they play in the online car retailing
space
and i don't think they've figured it out
i don't think i don't think they can
acquire companies because it has to be
the dna that changes it's actually a
very good example of the innovator's
dilemma
carmax is a great example carmax is
returning one and a half billion dollars
to its shareholders every year
yet corvanna is selling a third of the
con is worth three times as much
and so carmax is now have they're now
faced with this
this dilemma should i just continue this
business that returns tons of money to
my shareholders
or should i invest money into projects
initiatives
that change the dna that change the
return profile of my stock in my
business
that don't pay off short term but
position the business
more successfully long term and i don't
think
i don't think the car space has figured
it out to how to
how to react to somebody like caravan
acquire yet
and then the disadvantage of of existing
player is the longer you wait the bigger
carvana gets
and the bigger kervana gets you know
this flywheel the more powerful it
gets like it's a little bit like amazon
than reality
it really is an interesting thing to
kind of see a fully vertically
integrated business
attack kind of a market where the
incumbents have been caught on their
heels a little bit
uh because i think to your point um the
longer and longer they weigh
actually the harder it becomes to kind
of change course
right and if they wait too long you know
we know how that ends and that's not
pretty for
anyone involved with the incumbents
right i think i think car
dealers will play a different role in
the future you have the
manufacturers who build cars they're not
very good at selling and
neither are they allowed to so they have
their dealership networks
tesla already tried to change that and
made some strides but didn't
fully get through they're still having
dna licenses in different states
um and then the dealers used to make 10
gross margin in the car that's down to 8
now which
doesn't sound like a big difference but
that means 20 less profit on a card now
than 10 years ago
back-end revenues are going up and
margins that means for financing and
insurance products
but now the financing products are
becoming more transparent and
now they need they have feel more
competition on that level
um servicing is still in an opportunity
for franchise dealerships where you go
back and return your car but if it
becomes electric you don't have a lot of
service
so i i think the structures will
continue to exist i think car
dealerships will figure out slightly
different
business models if if it was for me i
think they should try to innovate around
ownership like you'll be really nice if
car ownership
could be temporary and could be a
subscription type of model
and you need to be vertically integrated
to offer that and i think dealership's
actually a really good position to
innovate on that front
um but i haven't seen anyone do
something really impressive in that
space quite yet and
i uh yeah i'm curious i'm actually
curious myself
before i go into rapid fire questions to
uh to wrap us
up uh what would be your best piece of
advice to first-time founders
um there is a piece of advice for people
who want to be founders and have yet to
figure out what to work on
that piece will be you just need to get
started it's really important
to get started because the second you
have conversations you learn something
that you didn't know
and it's so easy to talk out talk
yourself out of starting
if you only start the company in your
head and you're not doing anything so
step one is to
you need to get started and force
yourself to figure out how can you
provide value
that forces you to have conversation and
that allows you to learn
um once you're already starting i think
you need to be a lot more patient like
companies
if you look at companies you always
think they're an overnight success
they're always 10 years in the making
and so you need to end up being it for
the right reasons i feel really good
about what we're doing right now because
i have this north star and i don't i
don't care how long it will take
um i have the luxury to think like that
i wasn't the same person seven years ago
when i started it
because i was like ambitious and sure
impatient
um if i were talking to myself seven
years ago i would tell myself spent less
money
keep the burn lower for longer keep
learning
and really really find out what product
market fit means for you
and then double down and don't don't
think you have it when you're not sure
because that's dangerous
that's a great piece of advice uh i
asked the same two questions everybody
and then you get asked me one to finish
uh first is what is the most important
book you've ever read
most important or most recent um i've
read a book that i really enjoyed is
don't split the difference
or never split the difference it's about
i'm not sure we've read it it's about
this fbi hostage negotiator
who realized after iterating on how to
best negotiate that this is really
applicable to business
i really enjoyed that book not only
because it's entertaining because i
think it's
it's really really really teaching a few
valuable lessons and so
most important recently putting into the
whole my life's perspective it's a
little hard but that's a book that i
think of very often and i really enjoy
it
it's really good too because he almost
uses he uses like real life scenarios
right
to kind of explain the uh the the
different lessons which is uh pretty
cool
uh second question is more fun aliens
believer or non-believer
so i still want to go to area 51 i've
never been to check it out i want to see
with my own eyes
um i have seen no evidence i don't think
they're out there
but i don't think i think the chances
are non-zero that they exist somewhere
i think that's a very fair way to look
at it it's like uh the number one
answer for nowhere explanation for no i
don't believe is i haven't seen one
right uh and then the number one answer
for
yes is mathematically the probabilities
they exist
right you nailed both of them which is
uh not what most people say
what's the uh what's the one question
you have for me to uh to wrap this up
i'm i'm really curious to get a sense
for what what you feel like you're
getting out of these podcasts obviously
there's a lot of people listening to you
and i listened to a podcast two weeks
ago three weeks ago i really enjoyed it
and
it's clearly a big investment in time
and effort on your and what are you
getting out of it and what excites you
about it this is the most selfish thing
i do
like i tell people all the time uh it's
great i
enjoy that everyone else finds these
valuable but if nobody listened
i would still do that because you just
sat down and gave me a crash course over
an hour in the car industry
uh in building companies right kind of
all the things that you've learned
uh you're gracious enough to spend your
time with me and i get to steal all the
information right i feel like i like
extract it from you and like run away um
and so uh you know and i mean that in a
positive way but like that's basically
what happens to the conversation because
it's so one-sided right it's so unfair
uh the guest basically is is providing
you know majority of the value and i'm
just asking questions and learning
um and so as i've thought through it i'm
like if i didn't have the audience
right one it wouldn't be a very
compelling thing for
a guest to come on um so having that
audience is kind of the
the gift it back in exchange if you will
for hey you give us information i'll
give you this big platform
uh but also two i think is um more and
more
as i pay attention like why people say
they come on the podcast like
yes there are kind of self um you know
benefits right in terms like from my
company i can promote what i'm doing uh
but i really do think people have this
inherent
uh desire and uh enjoyment from giving
back to others
right so it's like hey i learned this
thing or i spend all day
thinking about this thing like i can go
and you know 45 minutes to an hour kind
of tell a whole bunch of people about it
like that's awesome right and i enjoy
doing that and so i don't know why it is
people that are like investors and
entrepreneurs but for some reason that
feeling of kind of wanting to give back
or kind of share
knowledge uh is really special i think
to uh to these industries
um it's cool to kind of be able to help
facilitate that yeah very cool
well thanks for having me i feel very
flattered to be here absolutely where
can we
send people to go find you on the
internet or find more about
i don't even know if we're allowed to
say the name of the company but you the
name is clutch
uh the url is with clutch.com it's a
prototype so
whatever you see take it with a grain of
salt and give me the
benefit of doubt that it's still a
prototype um
and then ideally connect with me on
linkedin uh look for my name nicholas
anderson you can put in the show notes
um i love to connect
with people um share thoughts ideas
if somebody has feedback from me i think
feedback is a gift so
be kind but generous and then if you
want my thoughts on something
if you happen to be in the car space
which is a space i've gotten to know
quite a bit feel free to reach out
awesome man list thank you so much for
doing this i really appreciate i think
people are going to love this
thanks for having me